so I got Pokemon uh you know Yu-Gi-Oh
and then another um game called like
flesh and blood I had somebody actually
call into the show the other day that
paid off their debts by selling um
Pokemon cards not even playing you can
find it on YouTube that's a real how
much money you think all of your cards
are worth truthfully uh well I know um
just give me a ballpark five grand it's
about like I'd say 70k
$70,000 yeah um I know the Market's a
little like rough right now but it's
about 70 I'm breaking the equipment here
I'm so excited Mikey listen dude do you
do you understand that your math
equation just changed you have 7,000 in
Robin Hood you have 70,000 in trading
cards and you have 40,000 in debt let's
go back to third grade math you're about
to be father of twins twin baby
girls if I'm you I'm like well my world
just changed I'm no longer in the
trading card business I'm in the dad
business